HE WAS A MASTER PROVOCATEUR.
HE STARTS TAKING ON,
LIKE, THE LOCAL POLITICIANS
AND POLICE FORCE.
HE WOULD JUST, LIKE,
TAKE JABS AT THEM
IN HIS WRITING FOR
LOCAL NEWSPAPERS AND [bleep].
HE WAS JUST LIKE, PFFT.
OKAY, WHAT DO I DO NEXT?
MARK TWAIN [bleep] UP.
HE IS STRAIGHT UP
A [bleep] AMERICA'S MOST WANTED.
AND HE GOES OUT
TO THE MIDDLE OF [bleep] NOWHERE
AND HANGS OUT AT THE LOCAL
[bleep] WATERING HOLE, SALOON.
THERE'S A GUY
WHO'S HANGING OUT THERE
WHO CONSTANTLY SPINS YARNS.
OH, I GOT A STORY,
MY NAME'S BEN COON,
AND I GOT A LITTLE STORY
FOR YOU.
THEY'RE LIKE,
[bleep] I DON'T WANNA HEAR IT.
I DON'T WANNA HEAR IT
NO MORE.
I KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
I KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT!
THERE'S MARK TWAIN
SITTING AT THE BACK OF THE BAR.
UH, I'LL [bleep] LISTEN.
BEN COON'S LIKE,
FINALLY.
SOMEBODY'S GONNA [bleep] LISTEN
TO MY BULL[bleep].
SO HE'S LIKE,
OKAY, HERE'S THE DEAL.
THERE'S THESE TWO DUDES
ARE PITTING FROGS
AGAINST EACH OTHER
IN A LEAPING CONTEST.
SO EVERYBODY ELSE IS JUST LIKE,
GOD DAMN IT,
I'VE HEARD THIS [bleep] STORY
100 TIMES.
AND ONE MAN SABOTAGES
THE OTHER MAN'S LEAPING FROG
BY FEEDING HIM
LEAD-FILLED BUCKSHOT
SO THAT THE OPPONENT'S FROG
CAN'T JUMP AS HIGH.
YEAH.
IT GETS THAT DIRTY
IN THE FROG JUMPING WORLD.
ANYWAYS,
MARK TWAIN'S JUST LIKE,
THIS IS AN AWESOME
[bleep] STORY.
YES! I'M GONNA WRITE
ABOUT THIS [bleep].
MARK TWAIN GOES BACK
TO HIS TYPEWRITER
OR WHATEVER THE [bleep]--
HIS COMPUTER--
AND GOES, BRRRRR.
I'M GONNA TRANSCRIBE THIS
IN THIS DULLED-DOWN,
EVERYMAN'S STORYTELLING.
BANG!
THAT STORY GETS PICKED UP
AND BECOMES A [bleep] HUGE HIT.
AND IT'S DESCRIBED AS
"STORY OF THE DAY!"
MARK TWAIN
HAS HIT THE [bleep].
WHAT HE'S DONE
IS AMA-ZING.